My name is Dave Bennent.
I'm a member of the team that restored this machine--the world's first hard disk drive.
It was announced in 1956 it was the first product of IBM's laboratory in San Jose, California.
This is a big machine with a very small capacity.
However, in 1956 it was very important.
This machine had 50 disks 24 inches in diameter.
It stores a total of 5 million 6-bit characters, 3.75 megabytes in today's world.
Any disk drive that doesn't have at least gigabytes in it is obsolete by modern standards.
It was actually designed to run a request from the Air Force
for storage capacity for their 50,000 spare parts inventory.
It was designed to hold 50,000 character records
with access to any records in less than a second.